welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is hisham azuz
today i'm delighted to be joined by
oliver cook
who leads the west coast and south coast
usa offices
for fading international across five
specialist brands
uh oliver joined the recruitment
industry straight out of university in
2011
and since then he has climbed the ranks
of one of the fastest growing
recruitment companies across the world
as well as
taking his career to the states and has
been there and
he's just sharing with me nearly more
time now than well the most time in his
adult life so
really interested to uh dig into your
story oliver and how are you
yeah i'm good i'm good i was just saying
i've got a bit of a cold so i'm sorry if
i sound a little bit congested but
um otherwise it's good it's friday uh
i'm in dallas and uh
the weather's awesome at this time of
year so it's uh yeah it's nice feeling
good
love it so where we start is
oliver what is your opinion in what
characteristics and traits that you
think
make up a highly successful recruitment
consultant
yeah i think that's a good one um you
know i i'm probably not going to say
anything that's uh
that that that people haven't heard
before right i think it's
i think first and foremost i'm a massive
believer in hard work beats talent
every single day of the week um and you
know if you don't have the work ethic
then you know regardless of how talented
you are building relationships
communicating with people
um or how charismatic you are if you
don't work hard
you're not gonna succeed you get be
you're gonna get beaten by
your competitors out there so i think
first and foremost is having the work
ethic the mentality the positive
attitude mental toughness
um competitive mindset you know all of
those things
that i think people would typically look
for a couple of things that i tend to
look for in
in uh from a mental aspect as well as
particularly in
junior people the way we hire people is
fairly organic you know we do
tend to focus on graduate hiring and
kind of build people from there but
sort of both the commercial awareness
of of how business works i think is
important um
and and not everyone has that naturally
um and and secondly sort of
a bit of a particularly if you're in
specialist markets
um the ability to learn quickly and the
ability to
and the enthusiasm to learn quickly as
well um
and i think that um you know having sort
of that intellectual curiosity to go out
there and actually learn your space
learn your market
become an actual expert um you know
we're living in the age of
the internet where um there's unlimited
resources to
to learn what you need to um so there's
no excuse really in
in my mind so i think first and foremost
the mental side and
and and that piece it's that um in terms
of skills
obviously you know the ability to
communicate the ability to build
relationships
um the ability to be authentically
yourself
and you know um and and and and
and persuade and convince people to to
to look at opportunities or or use your
service
um are all are all important things as
well interesting
how different obviously you as a
graduate right i saw you went to
is it portsmouth you went to correct
how different do you think the graduates
are when if you look at back who you are
in 2011 compared to the graduates that
you see now
and me do you think because a lot of
people talk about it right snowflake
generation whatever you want to call it
i didn't go to university
i i was born in 1993 so might be in that
bracket maybe but
what i don't know any distinct
distinction do you think
yeah i mean look i i i we're i think
millennials first and foremost get them
extremely bad rap right like us
millennials
you know everyone's always complaining
that like we don't do anything
we are a business that's been built
exclusively
on millennials so frankly i think it's
um
can i swear on this podcast yeah of
course you can come on
uh i think it's [ __ ] that you know
millennials don't work hard and don't
you know want to achieve things and be
successful um
and you know we i think we as a business
have proved that right we have 800
people around the world and i'd say the
vast majority are millennials
and one of the fastest growing
recruitment businesses in the world um
so i think
certainly our generation has has that i
definitely seen like kind of the newer
generation coming through i mean
you know i think every generation looks
down at the generation below and and
sort of like
you know i worked harder than you and
you know it was much harder in my day i
didn't even have linkedin and all the
rest of it
um but i i you know i i think
if you find the right people like i i'm
an optimist right like
everyone wants to be successful everyone
wants to
um you know achieve things in their life
even if it's down to
small things like owning a house or
sending their kids to college or
owning a car like small things like that
like
everyone has goals whether it be
financially or also in terms of your
career and
and uh you know i think you can find the
people that
will do that uh who have the right
motivations so
interesting so uh just for
for context for everyone i know we were
talking a bit before but a big chunk of
your recruitment career has been in the
leadership capacity
um so you just mentioned sort of where
sort of fade and international are today
but where what did fade in international
look like in your first year in
recruitment and
how would you describe your first gym
recruitment uh it's it's a very
different company to to what it was
10 years ago i'm now in my 10th year in
the business which
starts to make me feel quite old to be
honest but um
yeah it's it you know when i joined in
london we were a fairly
you know fairly typical london-based
recruitment business we were mostly
finance focused in terms of the markets
we covered
in terms of the culture it was you know
your standard kind of london recruitment
agency right like it was work hard play
hard
um there was good banter in the office
it was fun
like-minded people i think that was one
of the things i loved about it like i
made some of my best friends
that i still have to this day in that
first year in recruitment or people who
started around a similar time
as me in faden so
um you know it was kind of your fairly
typical
environment back then i think what we
always did have and what attracted me to
the business was
it was just this relentless ambition
that
was running through the entire business
and i even got that from the interview
process when i went in
and met them and that was super
inspiring um
and this idea of like you could be you
know you could be the ceo one day if you
wanted to
and um you know my boss who who hired me
harry yutan um you know had a team of
five people when i started and he's now
the global ceo
so i think we're one of those businesses
where
meritocracy is banded around sort of
willy-nilly in
in recruitment um these days and in most
businesses but
we are kind of an ultra meritocracy and
that's kind of proved out
by the people in the business you know
uh and where they are and where they are
now and how they've stayed with the
business and and growing with it
in terms of who we are now um you know
we're
we're you know we're obviously 800
people as i said globally
um 12 offices we're much more corporate
than we probably were 10 years ago
which i think is a good thing in in in a
lot of ways
comes with its own challenges with that
obviously as well and as you scale
there's there's
always growing pains um but it's been an
amazing journey and i
i've been very lucky from my own journey
in the business
and i feel very grateful and lucky that
i found this company specifically i've
had basically a different challenge in a
different role
for 10 years now 10 years in a row every
single year
and it's sort of like okay do this role
for three to six months
make it work probably screw it up a
little bit at the start and then you
know
do it well the next three months in the
final three months you'd finally get it
going really well and then they're like
okay cool new year new challenge go and
do this
um and we really do put a lot of faith
in
young ambitious people who who have
shown the ability to
to step up and like i said i feel i feel
very grateful and lucky that
i found a company like that so i love
that so
so just to sort of put that together
then so obviously saying so
for the last eight years you've been in
a sort of hands-off
role yeah and we'll break that down not
not not quite
um i spent a year and a half in london
and uh was obviously a biller there
learning the ropes and
learning how to how to do recruitment
and learning my market and then moved to
the us
in january 2013 um
and got the chance to build a team as we
we scaled that that new york office from
the
the five or six of us that moved out
here so did that in my
original market which was quantitative
finance um
and um then took on a wider role within
our selby jennings brand which is our
finance focus brand
um and then you know after i took on
that wider role of managing a couple of
deaths i went hands off at at that point
so that was probably about six years ago
or so okay
and yeah since then i'll be mostly hands
off still keep my
my hand in the game a little bit prove
it to the people that you can uh
get some goals on the board yeah exactly
yeah and i i you know i love the client
side of
of what of the business and what we do i
get massive buzz off that and
have always been very client-facing um
through any of my roles and that
you know something that that's important
to me and i think it's important to show
that to your people as well yeah so
right okay so a few things before we
we dig deep into leadership and and
mindset and
and scaling so what was the best piece
of advice you got early on in your
recruitment career
good question i think that
i i have this phrase that i call um that
i say that
the best recruiters are relentlessly
consistent
in terms of what they do every single
day recruitment is a game where
it's about a consistent amount of effort
and work over a period of time no one's
ever had one good day
and done a deal no one's ever had one
good week and done a deal or done
multiple deals right it's about
day after day week after week month
after month building that pipeline and
and being really consistent with the
activities and the things you do
day to day that produce the end result
and give yourself the best chance of
doing deals
and i think one of the things that our
founder um
said to to me one one day we were in new
york and
we were stuck in a snowstorm in a in a
cab
in new york on our way to a lunch club
and i thought i'd got him in a cave i
had him corn and so i was like i'll sort
of pick his brain a bit
and um i said you know who was the
the best recruiter you've ever seen he
he'd come from uh s3 in the past
and he said um firstly he said himself
which was not a surprise um and
and and we laughed and then he said no
actually there was a lady that
you know was that was at s3 and she was
just unbelievable she was
um you know everyone got 10 interviews a
week she'd get 20. everyone sent 20 cvs
a week she sent 40.
and she wasn't even necessarily
particularly talented
um at any one thing but she was just she
completely set her own standards
and it wasn't like okay the target is to
get to 10 interviews a week
hit 10 and then just you know sit back
and take your foot off the gas
or do one deal and take your foot off
the gas for the month and move on
she was just relentless and i really
took that to heart
and i remember when i started applying
that um that's when my
my billing took off as well love that so
relentless consistency and i think
combined with that what you just said is
also have
high standards right and so let me
answer this question i think this is a
great question
to um ask on on on top of that because
you've got some more insight
now so um i haven't got the person's
name that sent me this but i think it's
a great question so
it is um he said when you have a top
biller on
it would be interesting to know what
they think is the most
important action or kpi that contributes
to their success
what do you think that is
ultimately it's the amount of jobs that
you generate
right if you don't have a job platform
you can't place jobs
you know that that that that's pretty
simple for me right
having good business development um i
think that recruitment gets easy
once you get four five six clients that
hire consistently
have headcount actually partner with you
you know are you know who value your
partnership
and you build a really good relationship
with them
and um you know you get a consistent
flow of jobs from three four five
accounts
as an individual contributor that's the
dream right you can
you can then just fill them and and if
you're if you can build good
relationships like that
um and and and deliver jobs
you know every day every week you know
that that fall into your lap or that
generate from the activities you do
that you know after that
it's uh it's it's fairly simple in my
view so
yeah so um it's really interesting that
because i i think that's probably
i reckon there'll be a lot of people
that weren't recruited listen to this it
wasn't surprised by that
but it's definitely an area that
probably people
think that they can develop the most in
in terms of client development or they
find it the most difficult area
so like why why do you think that
recruiters
um have challenges in that area do you
think what are the common
sort of hurdles or common obstacles that
recruiters face that
prevent them from getting to the
position that you were just talking
about
well it's it's it's hard right
it's business development it's not easy
it there's a lot of rejection
you know you you get the doors slammed
in your face
and you know i i think it's not easy i
think
one of the biggest mistakes that people
make when it comes to bd is
they they get some success with one
activity
that produces results for example i spec
candidates out and i get jobs
um and then they'll revert back to that
because they've had a bit of success
doing that as they
they view that as the only way they can
pull jobs whereas
i'm sure if i went through the last five
deals we run
in faden um
out of those five deals that that job
that was placed was probably pulled
in five different ways one might have
been a spec
one might have been from a lead one
might have been from um
a client inquiry direct to us or from a
key account that we have
one might have been from a uh flipping a
senior candidate into a client
you know there are so many different
ways to develop business and pull jobs
as an as a 360 recruiter i think being
able to connect the dots on that
that's the number one thing that i don't
see people doing enough of
is doing it enough of business
development and keeping with it because
it is hard
like people give up on it pretty easily
and two doing enough
different types of activities that can
generate you jobs um
obviously there's a there's a skill to
to how you do some of those activities
and being
you know you develop that over time but
at the end of the day it's bd right it
is a volume based
activity yeah no
i think that's a really good insight
that you've shared there on on yeah
don't don't be one dimensional with that
that that i think that's a really good
point um but what what
because people always want to know like
what okay oliver but what is the most
effective way of doing it
people want to know the one wedge you
know what i mean but like what what have
you seen i guess if you were to put it
down to maybe
three core ways like what would you say
has been maybe for you personally or
for the highly successful recruiters
that you've seen grow like what
do you see be the most effective ways of
growing clients and
and growing your client development and
network
um i i don't think there's one
silver bullet right like i i think that
that question is is is the problem right
because
people think that there's like a silver
bullet there's this one way to pull
jobs and develop your business
ultimately once i think
going back to the point i made before
around developing
a client into an account that comes back
to you
once you get a job you've got to deliver
on it and you know you've got to deliver
for your clients
right and i think in the recruitment
industry sometimes there's not enough
focus on
client service and being
you know just just providing an amazing
service to your clients and delivering
ultimately
the candidate they want to hire who ends
up being because it's always you always
typically here
you always typically hear a lot i need
new clients new clients you know what i
mean so i guess
how how many of the sort of high high
achieving recruiters that you've seen
in fade and how how many of them would
you say actually have an effective
existing client strategy in terms of
growing
those clients into accounts i i think i
think they
they all do certainly in the us when
when we
i'll be honest like when we were in
london
we had grown very fast and to the point
when i joined the business 10 years ago
and i think we had
you know um some issues with client
relationships as a result of that it was
there was an approach at the time of do
the deal
don't worry about the relationship the
deals are most important right yeah
on to the next one and when we came to
the u.s we very consciously
talked about how we wanted to build the
business and we wanted to do it the
right way
um and build actual relationships that
lasted
over years and became better because we
are a perm focused business
that's super important to us from a
company valuation perspective as well
of we you know we need to show that we
can grow accounts consistently year
after year
with permanent fees um and we've been
really successful at that so we we did
implement a client services team
which is called the fade and partnership
group you know we do have a list of
twenty four what's their job sorry so
their job is
is purely client service and account
management
so it's really land and expand business
development within those accounts
they don't take any of the commission
away from our recruiters
so they get paid from a completely
separate part on a bonus um
on a bonus structure and um
you know their goal is just to enhance
that relationship
with that set of clients and you know
we've now got
a number of accounts across the us that
are in the multi millions of dollars on
an annual basis
from doing that and and you know that
strategy is paid off and
you know it's the world we live in today
like gone are the days where you can you
know sort of
you know throw a deal in and not not
follow process with
hr and sign terms at the end and kind of
thumb a deal in um without
you know following process and
developing the relationship so yeah so
real quick
on that because i think people be
interested like so let's just talk about
from this
angle what so they've one you've got
dedicated resource developing that
amazing
um and so i guess what do you see
let's say there'll be a lot of typical
360 recruits that don't have that
resource right or dedicated team that do
that so i guess from your perspective
what do you
see 360 recruiters typically do wrong
that prevents them from turning that
client that might be spending
100 gram of them a year or less than
that to that client becoming a 200 300
grand client would you say what are the
typical things that the people who
do wrong i think it is uh the point i
made earlier caring too much about the
deal
versus the relationship as well and how
to develop that
um and um
not following process with hr not
following process with with with the
client
going outside of that and maybe they end
up doing a deal off the back of it but
the hr then goes okay great you've done
a deal but we don't want to work with
you again
because you didn't follow what we wanted
you to do um
i i think that's one of the number one
things um
i also believe like we're in one of the
most relationship driven businesses in
the world right at the end of the day
you know it's cliche but people do buy
from people and
if you are able to get past the the
transactional nature that sometimes is
there with
recruitment and into a personal
relationship with your clients
where they want to work with you they
want to partner with you
versus seeing you as a sort of necessary
evil
um i think that's that's that's the key
right
yeah for sure okay then final thing what
might not be the final thing but just
real
quick one on sort of client development
real a bit granular here but i'm sure
it's something that
comes up a lot in conversations for you
from people but
this this always gets message to me like
what
i'd love to hear your thoughts on how
your people get over the we work to a
psl objection
i'm sure that i don't know how if that's
even more common in america
but like it's just something i always
get messages about like i don't know if
you've picked up on things or picked
like what what's what typically comes up
for you when you when you hear people go
ollie i just can't like they're telling
me they went to psl i just don't know
how to
crack this account what comes up for you
yeah absolutely i mean i think it's
again taking that long-term approach
and being open to it yeah okay we do
work through uh to
towards a psl but um
you know how can i win your business um
and and staying in touch with that
contact at least if you've got to that
person that's telling you that
that's better than no response at all um
and then developing the relationship
from there like a bunch of accounts
our biggest account in the us right now
which is a
a large hedge fund um we tried to crack
them open for
for five six years right and and we
worked on it and
you know eventually we got there they
gave us a chance when they did give us a
chance we delivered
then we delivered again then we built
the relationship and then
now you know we're doing two you know
two plus million dollars a year with
that
single account do you think recruits
underestimate the power of follow-up
absolutely it's all follow-up that's
that's
that you know that sending one email and
not getting a response going i i bd that
client
like that that's that's not the game
right it's it's
it's all about follow-up and then when
you do get a no that's better than no
response
so you've opened the conversation now
and you can you can then develop the
relationship from there
um and and look at the end of the day if
some clients have psl they don't want to
work with you there's hundreds or
thousands of others
in your market that you can work with so
don't waste i always have a rule with my
guys of
spenders spend you know put as much time
into clients as they put into you
and that goes for business development
as well if they very clearly don't want
to work with you and you've tried
a number of times you keep in touch with
them move on
like there's always another client that
you can work with yeah
and and at some point they may come back
around and
and may work with you in the future if
you keep in touch and keep up the
follow-up
yeah okay so let's let's dig into um
leadership only so like firstly i have
to ask you like you've mentioned some
big numbers you joined an organization
where
yeah there's close to 100 people there's
now 800 people in the organization so
why why why is it do you think that
oliver cook has
sort of ended up taking on the
opportunities and responsibilities that
you have
um and and not your colleagues like
why is it ended up being you do you
think um
look i i think like i said as i'm
trying to be a bit humble with it but um
i i am
lucky and grateful that i joined the
company i did
that puts a lot of responsibility and
trust in young ambitious people
and not every business is like that when
we got moved to the us they
you know the five or six of us were all
in our early to mid twenties i was 23
and they basically said look here's a
million bucks gonna make it work
um which was an amazing opportunity
prid pretty daunting um we
i'd been to new york for three days when
i was 12. um so
that was pretty weird walking through
times square the first time being like
i live here now um and
i i think you know first and foremost i
i'm very lucky that i work in a company
that gives me the opportunity to step up
and do that
secondly um look i think
i was i have always been good at
um teaching recruitment and coaching
people how
to do the job um and
doing it in a way that that hopefully
makes sense and explaining the why
behind everything
and um you know making them quite
skillful
at what they do um and then in hopefully
inspiring them to to work hard and and
achieve what they want to achieve
after they know how to do the job um i
think you know if you're a billing
manager
that that's the key thing right you know
get good at at
teaching how to do the job um and how to
to make people good at what they do
rather than just giving them a phone and
a computer and going
go make some calls and see what happens
um
and and then you know afterwards it's
all about
inspiring and motivating and encouraging
people uh and and making them better um
i'd
like i think obviously a lot of people
get into recruitment because there's a
lot of rewards
um financially progression things like
that
i think the best managers that i see are
really passionate about developing
people
i think that goes for any industry uh
but particularly recruitment where it
becomes a game of scaling
i believe in if you create you're not a
leader until you create a leader who
creates another leader
and that's what the game is about at the
end of the day so i've spent a lot of my
time in the last
you know five or six years creating
leaders beneath me
who can also do the things that i
mentioned
right and that's how i think you know
how we operate as a business at faden as
well
um because we are an organically grown
business we very rarely make experienced
hires particularly at the management
level
um and that that gives us some
weaknesses in some ways being that
insular but
i think it's a massive strength of ours
as well um
so you know really that i think it's
those three
things that have kind of helped me be
successful so far
okay interesting so and then uh i'd love
to know this then like what do you think
of like the free non-negotiables of the
failing culture
that everyone admires to three
non-negotiables
do you think makes fade and fade in this
like yeah
that's really what what everyone about i
mean i
i i'm trying not to give you the
corporate answer and i'm trying to give
the the real answer
[Laughter]
i think i think i think back in the day
right i get i'll give you the corporate
answer and then i'll give you the
what i think is the real answer as well
yeah okay so um
the corporate answer is you know ability
character loyalty that's our three
values
yeah and i do actually believe like
although it's a bit of a cliche
corporate thing to talk about
i do think that is consistent across our
business right okay
organically grown people are loyal to us
we are loyal back to them
you know an example of that is
throughout this pandemic
we didn't cut any commissions or any
salaries for anyone in our business
because we were very aware that the
people driving the value in the business
are the ones that are there day-to-day
that hit in the phones that are
building the relationships and doing the
deals to disincentivize them in an
environment like we've all just been
through
like we have to sell our way out of what
this position we're in
and we took that view and as a result
you know we've actually
held up really well throughout the
crisis character
you know like like i said you know we
put a lot of trust and value in
in in young ambitious people that want
to step up and want to succeed
and and likewise with ability like if
you show the ability
to step up in this business we'll we'll
give you the the chance to do it
um so that's probably the corporate
answer um and and uh
i you know the the real answer is like
we don't have anything proprietary that
no one else has right like our people in
our culture
are who we are and like you know we used
to say back in day work hard make money
have fun
right that sounds that sounds like kind
of cheesy a little bit now but like
it at the heart of it like that's the
environment
we want to create where people do work
really hard
you do get rewarded for it and while you
do it you have fun
with like-minded people and you know you
can develop your career with that
so um that's what i'd say
interesting so let me ask you this thing
because i feel like you would have come
up against this like
how have you gone about leading and
creating leaders
in sort of areas of this business that
you
previously haven't worked in as a
consultant
definitely and and you know i've i've
i've been through that the last couple
of years i like finance has kind of been
my bread and butter the financial
services world and
in the last 18 months i've moved into a
role where
i'm managing a number of offices across
all of our brands so
um we have a life sciences brand we have
a
uh infrastructure and renewables
brand engineering brand a supply chain a
procurement brand we have a tech brand
and then we have our fs brand which is
is our largest
business um so that was always my
comfort zone and i've had to
to step out of that particularly in the
last 18 months
and it's definitely challenging
ultimately i'm not gonna go
and work with a leader who's the best
um at um you know life sciences
recruitment
in the market and tell them how to do
their job
and recruit in that market better than
them they've done that for five years
i'm never going to add value for them in
that world
but i do think that leadership and
coaching and development is consistent
across
any market and there are some
recruitment
skills that are also obviously
consistent across any market and
i think that's where i've i've tried to
add value for people of like okay how do
you build a team how do you retain
people
how do you develop that person from one
deal every three months to
to to eight deals a year or ten deals a
year
um and and being a value add on that
side is
is where you gotta be right like as you
progress you you know you're not always
gonna
manage people in a market that you fully
understand or know really well
obviously gaining some initial basic
knowledge of that market helps and
understanding the nuances of that space
um and how they
how to recruit because it does vary but
ultimately it's
it's more about how can i add value to
you from from my experience and
it's more around that sort of leadership
development and people development piece
nice yeah so making sure that you go
into those situations with the humility
to be like look i know
i know i probably can't add value this
this area but i can add value in these
areas and then
work away from that point yeah that's
that's really interesting then so
i guess just just on that then if you
work with a lot of people like that i
think you i'm sure you've you've heard
this saying that the sort of billing
the billing manager is the most
difficult role in in recruitment
um well what do you see what do you
typically then
help leaders with them get better at or
improve that
that um you typically find yourself
doing with people
um i think a big weakness of my own was
was definitely time management and
organization and
being having structure to the way that
you do things
and so i had to learn the hard way
through a lot of mistakes
that you need to have all of those
things
those are things that i'm not good at
naturally and so
um i i think that's something that i've
been able to help people with
i think how you manage your business how
you spot problems
ahead of time uh how you can be a
proactive versus a reactive manager
um how you how you train somebody to
manage
which is is is also not easy to do
um yeah that that's something that i've
always kind of worked on
um you know how do you drive activity
without being a kpi monster
right how do you inspire and motivate
somebody to
to to set their own standards like i
said earlier um
and and go above and beyond without
being like
send some more [ __ ] tvs right yeah
and and you know i think i think there
is a skill
to that which hopefully i i do i mean
now and again i may have said that
uh but you know we try and avoid that
right it's more about
explaining the why behind things how can
you inspire somebody to go abundant
versus
the stick if that makes sense yeah yeah
for sure that was one of the questions
that
i definitely had down if you look at
your organization and the world that you
live in there's going to be so many
systems that fade and have and
we have the fading way of doing things
and that would have been a big part as
to why you scaled right
but i think there's then like your
experience sharing one of the
questions i wrote down was like that
sort of you can be
you can potentially go too
far one side which is over emphasis on
kpis which can then potentially be
counter-intuitive
right in terms of people's performance
and activity so it's interesting you say
that so i guess
this comes up a lot it's all it always
comes up around drivers which is
typically the word right you're saying
why
and for them to encourage them to over
perform and set their own standards but
i guess how have you and i'm sure you've
obviously put together maybe a bit of a
system now got better at working out
how to encourage consumers to find out
their drivers or
what their drivers are like is that is
that being important do you think
yeah absolutely i mean i you know we try
to
figure that out in the interview process
itself obviously
excuse me i think everyone's got a
i think particularly when you're hiring
young graduates
for me i like to hire people that have a
self-awareness
where how do you look for that so i i
think you know it's asking people like
do they understand their weaknesses
like i you know the typical interview
question is tell me about your biggest
weakness everyone has a canned answer
prepared for that right
right you're style i'm a perfectionist
right okay thanks um
so i asked them for naming your top five
weaknesses
and by three or four they really have to
think about it and they start being
honest
or somebody that sits there and can't
tell me five weaknesses okay you're 21
years old
you're a graduate and you're already the
finished article
probably not the case right so um you
know that
i people have a self-awareness and i
think is
is very important and people who know
themselves
tend to understand their why what gets
them out of bed in the morning
um and and that will change for people
over time
obviously with with different priorities
and things like that
but you know we always like to establish
that in the interview process
i have this um thing that i talk about a
lot called the eight great working
habits
again it sounds a bit cheesy but i i
learned i i learned i learned
i learned them doing door-to-door sales
at university where i literally walked
around with a bag selling makeup
which was which was kind of weird and
embarrassing at times
but it taught me a ton about rejection
and business development and building
relationships and
all the rest of it um i didn't wear the
makeup
[Laughter]
sometimes but um yeah so it was
that the last one on those eight great
working habits is remember why you're
here and what you're doing it for
and i think if you know for for any of
whatever career you're in right whether
it's recruitment or anything else i
think if you
when things don't go well when things
don't go your way when you have a bad
week a bad month
a bad day whatever that's the thing that
gets you through it
is knowing your why and knowing why you
get out of bed in the morning and
remembering that
and you know i talk about that a lot to
my guys and
the people that i manage because if if
you don't know what that is you need to
figure it out quick because you will
have those days all those weeks all
those months
where it is [ __ ] and you know it's not
going your way
and um you need to get through it so
that that
that's a that's something that i talk
about a lot yeah interesting so
just just to build on that and then i'd
love to just um pick your brain around
the nuances of the u.s
market and i think you're very well
positioned to talk about
what you've learned along the way and i
think there's loads of recruitment
businesses
wanting to expand internationally and
some get it right some get it wrong but
i guess obviously you you as you've
shared advice
you've become very successful at
developing fresh talent right and i
think
a lot of recruitment businesses ideally
would want to be able to grow
fresh tannin like fade and have right um
but this question i have that sort of
someone sent over is like
something that i guess you have to deal
with as a manager is
how you help people that doubt
themselves like how do you actually help
people overcome that doubt so you're
talking about the anchor point of their
why
but a lot of this and when i speak to a
lot of recruiters on here that might
have three four five years experience
a lot of the reasons why maybe they
didn't excel in the first year is
confidence
so like how what's been your what's been
yeah
learnings on that on like how you've got
better people actually
being getting better and not doubting
themselves yeah i mean like confidence
naturally comes with success
um you know when when you get you know
when you see the process through when
you do the deal it's going to come but
i always say to to my guys in the
onboarding process
build build build right tell like
celebrate the small wins
even if it's the pulling a lead or you
know
like getting a great candidate in or
just the basics of the job
celebrate those wins and build someone
up half the battle with a graduate who's
in their first job is convincing them
that they can do it
like and i massively believe in that
like build them up
reinforce that that and and reinforce
that positivity and
encourage them to to know that they can
do it
because like i said at the beginning
recruitment is an accumulation of small
gains
over a period of time and if you can get
somebody
excited about pulling a lead excited
about generating a really good candidate
excited about having a good conversation
with a client
um that's half the battle and then
the rest of it kind of follows from
there um
so yeah like giving them the confidence
they can do it
just by positive reinforcement
is there i think getting
like the onboarding process with that
generally is is super important
um you know how do you get somebody
comfortable
coming to the office in a it's their
first job how do you get them
you know like making sure they make
friends across the office right i said
it before like a big part of who we are
is we have fun while we do it
and it's pointless if you're not having
fun so
you know hopefully you know we do a good
job of kind of
making people feel comfortable when they
join us quickly
and you know if you feel comfortable
getting out of bed and getting to the
office every morning and you're making
friends and you're enjoying
the people around you the work's going
to become
more enjoyable as well so those are the
things
i like that yeah build the build i
really like that so
um ollie like how would you that how
would you sort of wrap up maybe in like
two or three things like the main
differences
in terms of the nuances of being a
recruit in the american market that
people should be aware of if i don't
know thinking about expanding into
america
or um are in the process of doing at the
moment what are the main sort of
cultural
nuances or differences you think from a
recruiting perspective that we need to
know about
i i think there's a lot right
we're quite different uh us english and
brits versus the uh
versus the us much more than i realized
before i moved here
i think i always say we moved here like
we didn't know what we didn't know
um and we just sort of like or a bunch
of 20 somethings moved out
we i think we had a collective
experience across the
six or seven of us of like 15 years
recruitment experience
like like cumulative um we were pretty
junior guys and so like
we had to learn from our mistakes pretty
quickly um
even down to like using american
spellings
in your emails versus english spellings
like putting a z in there versus an s
and stuff like that because you do that
in the us and some people think you
can't spell
right they they don't know that in
england we spell it differently so
it's small things like that um what what
i did love about coming to the us is
recruitment is a much less developed
market it's less much less saturated
and the industry as a whole is seen as a
much more professional industry
than maybe it's perceived as in the uk
um and clients and candidates treat you
accordingly
right i used that phrase earlier sort of
a necessary evil
i think that's less you know that
there's less of that perception
in the u.s and sort of head hunting as
they tend to call it here or
recruitment is seen as that profes
as a very professional industry that is
changing as
it's becoming more mature here over the
last seven eight years and particularly
a lot of british companies like
ourselves and
others that have come here and scaled
really fast um
but i always loved the fact that i felt
a bit more respected
by a client here and and a bit seen a
bit more as a partner versus
as somebody who's like you know i think
it's really unfortunate in the uk
um recruitment is amazing because
anybody
with any background can pick it up and
change their lives
um and if they have the work ethic and
the talent to do it
um but at the same time because of those
low barriers to entry
there are you know there are people some
of the standards can be low yeah
the standards get get reduced and and
there are people that maybe
you know shouldn't be in the industry
and it gives
you know the perception that you know it
gives the industry a bad name at times
and
um that's a shame because i love the
industry
it's it's it's certainly like changed my
life and i've seen it change
a lot of lives you know for whether it
be friends or
people in our business um but
i i think it's quite nice in the u.s
that it doesn't have that perception
yet um and and so that's good
good thing are the fees bigger
yes our average deal size in the us is
bigger than our average deal size in the
uk
um and so yes you can generally
i think back to the original point right
like
because it's less saturated there aren't
people driving down the fees by
undercutting everyone else and reducing
the overall standard of the work done
at the same time i think if you work in
in
markets where it's over broke where it
is saturated
if you're going to go and do accountancy
recruitment in the us
the fees are going to be the same or
lower than they are in the uk
or basic i.t recruitment
i think where we've done well is we've
always focused on that
those business critical spaces where
it's under broke and there's not a lot
of competition
and it's really that mid to senior level
talent that
is hard to find and
you know kind of that needle in a
haystack that no one else can find
and being real specialists within those
markets um
if you do that then the fees are
definitely bigger so
yeah and then so you've got i mean that
you've been there for a long time
like how how do you see it as you've
said there there's a lot of different
um uk originally obviously um agencies
starting in the uk
going to the us like how do you see it
shaping up so like you mentioned like it
seems like maybe there might be some
more saturation obviously
um but like how do you see it shaping up
over the next sort of
three to five years with probably more
and more uk firms going over to the us
yeah definitely definitely and that's
it's a compliment to us and and others
that have done it that
you know people have seen that some of
the success that
that that we're having and want to
replicate that
um so i i there will be more competition
inevitably but
at the same time i think that
you know that we've all learned a lot
this year now it's about ourselves about
our businesses about
the world we live in and it's been a
it's been a pretty crazy year for
everyone
i think that one of the results off the
back of this year is that
we've seen is is the strength of client
relationships that you've built in the
past
when the times are bad those are the
clients that will
will rely on you and you'll rely on them
and i think if you're a business that
doesn't operate that way then you'll
always struggle
um to scale and and also to
to go through those those harder times
um that's definitely something i've
learned
this year and and it's been a big
positive for us
um as a business as well so so do you
think that's where typically uk firms
might get it wrong then is that not
invest
enough into the decline relationship
side because isn't it
isn't it quite the norm then to have
this sort of setup that you have in the
us that more sort of 180 model where you
have people just focusing on
the client side and people focus on
delivery so do you think that's where
people could potentially slip up is it
is not yeah maybe taking the crime
relationship part for granted or
not investing enough in it yeah in my
experience
yes um it's it's
you know again i said earlier the fact
that we're so insular and we've all
grown up in the business um you know
i've i've done a lot more networking the
last
couple of years um you know within the
industry
than i have prior but you know i don't
know a lot about how other
businesses operate to be honest um and
like like i said that that's a strength
and a weakness for us
um you know we we have a way of doing
things and we have the things we believe
in and we think we do them very well
and we tend to focus on that versus
focusing on what
other people don't do well or do better
than us or
or whatever and and you know like i i
think we could do more of that so it's
difficult for me to
answer that question because i just i
don't necessarily know how other
businesses operate
what i will say is if you look at the
big u.s recruitment firms like
the the k forces of this world and
um insight global and and kind of some
of these other businesses that are
pretty large and have scaled pretty fast
they you know do have that 180 model and
that's a lot more common out here
but again i think where we've taken
market share away from some of those
firms is the 360 model does work well
if you're a specialist recruiter and
there aren't many uh
large u.s recruitment companies that
operate that way so
yeah i think that's the other thing i
picked up and nuances of like yeah they
like if i get olly the business owner is
a client i'll say yeah
i can do all your recruitment rather
than i'll do that mid to senior job
title and only that
which is obviously way more common in in
the uk
um but to to as you come to the end here
then
like just to tie that together then so
if i'm recruiting listening right now
and my business plan in 2021 is to take
my market from the uk to the us
what's your your three tips to me mate
what would you be saying to me if i was
in the process of expanding into the us
yeah absolutely i think the three things
um are things that we have always done
when we've launched new locations new
offices
is do it with an organic team right
don't go and hire in
some director from the us who may know
the market but doesn't know you as a
business
because i think the danger is if you do
that and then you hire a bunch of other
experienced people
you know who are local whatever you just
end up franchising your business
you know you if you're big enough and
doing well enough to expand to a new
location new geography
trust in the people that got you there
in the first place and and grow
organically so
whenever we launch an office you know we
we always try and make sure that
we go with an organic team of at least
four or five
um and we've done this now with seven
offices in the us um
at least four or five that grown up
understand us understand how we operate
um and can go into that new market and
replicate it there so that's number one
so be pre just quickly i think it's like
be protective of that because i think
you may think you might have the perfect
person you might think you may not view
it as a bit of a shortcut but it might
be the quicker route might in it to
to go down the route of hiring someone
that knows that market but yeah be
protective of your culture
and what you yeah what you know that
works and
and go yeah and trust in the people that
want to go out there hopefully if you
can find them
internally in the business and and move
them out there to start it because
that's how you you create a we call it
like a kind of golden thread
within your business where the culture
is consistent across lots of locations
i think where other companies struggle
is they go right we're going to launch
in the us
let's hire five locals and try and
replicate what we do
it's not going to work because it's
going to be franchise they're going to
do it differently
so that's number one i say number two is
work in that market from afar develop a
client base and a candidate base
and and develop that before you actually
land
so um yeah let's just just quickly i've
heard that before let's make that a bit
clear like what
i know it's different different markets
but what would you say a lot of the core
metrics that you're looking forward to
like you know what
yeah i'm confident and that we've got a
market there we're talking
i don't know x amount of clients we
talking get your billings to x you know
i mean what would you say the sort of
typical barometers that you'd look for
to be like yeah
let's do it so we we tend to look at
at least a million dollars done in that
region
okay to to warrant opening an office and
the potential to grow that office to 50
people
i think nice unless you can grow that
office to 50 people
like there's not really much point in
launching it you can plan for why
well i i think by 50 you can get the the
scale where it actually becomes a profit
center that's
that's valuable to the business right
like
yes you can you can make a decent amount
of profit with 20 people or 30 people
but they all have to perform really
really well right if if you're gonna
generate an amount of profit let's call
it a million dollars plus
in a in a location you're going to need
50 people really
because you know then you you know half
them won't do a deal every month
perhaps um and the other half will um
and and to get to that level where
you're generating uh
an actual value-add amount of profit
then is is kind of 50 that that that's
what we look for
um and then so like doing a million
dollars before you actually land kind of
proves out that concept that
that is scalable and you can do it there
and then go with an organic team
um that's the third tip then yeah what's
the final thing
the final tip um
third tip i would say um
be open to to new ideas and new ways of
doing things as well
like i know that might be slightly
contradictory to
my first point about keeping that
consistent culture
you know like at the same time like
we've learned a lot
since we came here and like i said we
didn't know what we didn't know
and we made a lot of mistakes like we
did screw some things up
like it hasn't been a smooth ride all
along the way
um and we've learned a lot from those
like like i said the culture is
different out here
like we are a different kind of business
to the one we are in london and europe
right like it we do operate slightly
differently
the same values are consistent but
the culture is different right like the
culture's different in hong kong and
singapore
to what it is in new york um and i think
being
accepting of that even i think we found
in the us as we've gone to different
regions in the us
it's different even in the us and the
culture is different in california to
what it is in new york
it's different in texas to what it is in
boston and so
i think having that that that sort of
golden thread like i said of values that
are consistent
and similar ways of doing things but
also being
open to managing people and your teams
and your business slightly differently
based on the culture is is important as
well yeah so i guess what you're also
saying there is respect the culture
isn't it and
don't don't sort of think or make the
decision that it's like it shouldn't be
this way
you know what i mean and yeah so i
really like that so
okay got five quick five questions
for you before we fly away all right so
first one
is if you could change the industry what
would you want
to improve
i i i said it earlier i think um
higher barriers to entry will improve
the standards
what book have you read that has had the
biggest impact on you
how to win friends and influence people
by dale carnegie yeah that's an absolute
crack of that one it's a great one
if uh so if you could write a linkedin
post
that could be seen by every single
recruitment consultant
across the world what would you want it
to say
good one um i'm i'm gonna be kind of
like
selfish in that i'd i'd like more oh
it's not a faded job advert is it
yeah that's i can't really say that can
i um
i uh yeah i mean look like
we we i i think i we would like to
publicize us
what you know what we've done more so if
i can talk about
you know our journey a bit like we've
had on on on this hour while i was
really open to doing this
i think that's that's a big plus because
you know hopefully whether it inspires
you know
somebody to work in their own company
harder and and do something different or
new or
join us you know that that that's a good
thing right so
yeah that's fair enough um what did you
spend
your first biggest commission paycheck
on
that's a fun one um so
uh it was funny he says can i tell a
story on this yeah of course you can
so um i well i did a couple of deals
quite quick
in the first few months i joined the
business but they're all three month
notices
so we pay a month in a rear on invoice
right so
uh after candy starts we'll pay the next
month
and so i had three deals kind of stacked
up and i was about six months into the
job
and i i was on an 18 000 pound base
salary right like it was
peanuts at the time as most people start
on in recruitment and yeah yeah
and i i was at the point where i was
having to make a packed lunch every day
and i had to borrow money off wonga.com
that the last week before i got that
paycheck because i was too proud to ask
my parents for money
and i borrowed money off wonga.com 150
quid
just to buy my pack lunch and get me to
work every day
and then i knew i was getting about it
was about 11 000 pounds
something like that which was for me it
was like i was yeah that's big i
thought i was [ __ ] loaded at the time
um yeah exactly so
um we yeah i i had my mate's birthday
party on the saturday and i thought it
was coming in on the monday
i woke up on a saturday morning and i
just thought
i'll uh i'll check whether it's coming
why not and
i looked in my bank account and it was
sitting there and i was i was
well you did see where you got more
money i wonder i think i think i'd yeah
i paid longer back straight away
i think i did a ravenelli around the
house like i was
um and so uh yeah i and then we went out
and had a very
very big night that night so really um
that's that that's probably the first
thing i spent my money on and then pay
back uh
paid back all my credit cards so awesome
love that mate
um last one what's
the ultimate goal for your recruitment
career
tough one um
it's tough right like for mike i i don't
know whether recruitment career is the
right answer or career in general
like i want the same things as everyone
else right like you wanna
you want um to be rewarded for your hard
work and
and you know whether that you know
financially and
through significance and progression and
and things like that
um you know those those things are
important to me
uh but ultimately like if i look back on
my career now so far and there's there's
a long way to go
but i think we've we've also like
impacted a lot of people
whether that be people who've joined us
as a business who may have gone
gone and left and gone on to do great
things elsewhere or
people that are still with us and like
that's something that's personally like
really inspiring for me day to day now
of like
seeing people progress and seeing them
succeed
and not just about my own achievements
but like
seeing that and i think you know i'm a
big believer that and i talk about this
with
the managers that i work with as well of
like be unselfish be more
more motivated about their success than
your own because
you know everyone hates that selfish
manager that's clearly in it for
themselves
um and so i i think that that's quite a
cool thing and
it's kind of intangible to say that
right there's you can't really
put something specific on that but being
able to look back in
ten years time from now and be like cool
like all these people
that have worked for us or worked with
us or
even clients that we've helped like a
lot over the years and worked with
for years and years being able to be
involved in that i think is pretty cool
so
yeah amazing oh it's been an absolute
pleasure thank you you too mate thank
you very much